édition spéciale sur tv filet nous
revenions notamment sur l'une des
grandes questions irc cette question de
l'abstention finalement allé plus
importante sur le plan national en 2010
est qu'en 2012 pour ce premier tour elle
s'établit à 21 77 %
qu'en est-il dans les yvelines alors sur
le département situation inverse au plan
national l'abstention baisse par rapport
à il ya cinq ans 21,18 % en 2012 contre
18,66 % ce dimanche c'est donc une
baisse assez significatives tout de même
précisons que plus de sept cent soixante
dix mille personnes au total se sont
déplacés aux urnes pour ce premier tour
de la présidentielle dans les yvelines
le département des yvelines qui fait
figure de bon élève en ile de france
puisque en région parisienne
l'abstention dépasse légèrement les 20 %
pour s'établir à 20,11 % les yvelinois
étaient donc nombreux à se mobiliser
pour ce 23 avril écouter ces quelques
réactions que nous avions recueilli
dimanche après midi dans le parc des
sources de la bièvre à guyancourt
oui j'ai été votée parce que c'est notre
débat des citoyens et que on a
l'occasion de donner notre voix à 18 et
19 ans je voudrais que vous me le fais
je pense que c'est important parce qu'on
nous donne l'occasion de voter donc même
si c'est pas c'est pas très claires et
au final on va choisir plutôt le moins
pire c'est un droit qu'on a et chez
droit là on peut pas nous l'enlever donc
il faut aller voter parce que c'est
important enfin on est la jeunesse et je
pense que c'est important de faire peser
son vote
surtout quand le cadre d'élections à la
présidentielle franchement je m'en fiche
mais c'est pas un peu pour sa route et
sinon moi je voterai pas franchement
parce que je trouve que c'est nul on
fait voter sarin et puis je parle ainsi
de rester en france plus tard pour ma
part j'ai voté parce que je trouve ça
important que chacun puisse exprimer son
ses opinions et voilà je pense que
forcément un candidat qui correspond
j'estime que c'est un droit qu'on a et
c'est important de le respecter certains
ne l'ont pas donc il faut agir en tant
que citoyen et surtout c'est une
élection plus qu'importante dans
l'histoire de notre pays
l'abstention niveau national
l'abstention dans les yvelines qu'en
est-il à saint quentin en yvelines dans
l'agglomération alors à saint quentin en
yvelines où il fait il ya deux communes
qui ont moins voté que les autres et
c'est malheureusement une habitude pour
elle désormais ce sont deux villes ancré
à gauche la verrière plus de 31 %
d'abstention pour ce premier tour et
rappelé le fief électoral de benoît
hamon 29,1 % de non votants al'inverse
parmi elles les bons élèves de
l'agglomération retrouve montigny le
bretonneux magny les hameaux et mention
spéciale pour voisins le bretonneux
seulement 15 % d'abstention c'est quatre
points de moins qu'en 2012 pour voisins
le bretonneux
merci nicolas stéphane samson est ce que
l'on peut en tirer des enseignements
dans le cadre du second tour est ce que
l'abstention va rester faible pour le
second tour plus inquiétante enfin
l'histoire l'histoire montre que
lorsqu'un premier tour et couronnée
d'une participation assez forte comme
c'est souvent le cas et comme ça a été
le cas en dépit de ce qu'on avait pu
envisager bien montre que le second tour
suit cette même dynamique en règle
générale à quelques quelques des cils
prêts y avait une crainte pour le
premier tour sur la sur la participation
sur un taux élevé d'abstention
finalement les français ont décidé de se
mobiliser d'aller aux urnes
qu'est-ce qui a pu comme ça elle est
décidée parce qu'il y avait aussi
beaucoup d'indécis alors ce qui ce qui a
pu les décider c'est que je pense que
les français ont toujours le goût de la
politique et surtout ce qui pourtant la
campagne a été longue à mr plus à la
campagne a été très longue mais je les
meetings était relativement remplis
enfin tout dépend pour qui pour la
plupart des candidats je pense que ce
qu'on peut en conclure ce qui serait
quand même un enjeu aussi
il y avait un enjeu peut-être comme il
n'y a jamais eu jusqu'à présent avec
quatre candidats qui se tenait par la
barbichette les uns par rapport aux
autres il y avait un véritable danger
avec une cristallisation comme on dit
qui est intervenu de manière très
tardive pas avant les 3 semaines à
quinze jours qui ont précédé le scrutin